what's up clatter fans Josh McKoon here
with Cameron Monaghan from anthem of a
teenage profit hatin list of the new
movie anthem of a teenage prophet
Congrats on the movie man it's it's a
really it's hard to kind of describe but
it's like a dark coming of age yeah
right it's it's but it's God oh yeah I
would say I would say that that's about
accurate I would call it a young adult
movie but I don't feel that it's
pandering in the way that a lot of young
adult movies are I think it's a movie
about teens and I think it is for teens
but it's not it's not targeted in a way
of like oh this is so a hit for like
adults making it for kids right like you
guys like this stuff it's like no this
is like we're just gonna make it about
experiences of like what we felt as
teenage yeah and that means that there's
a lot of joy there's a lot of passion
there's a lot of love and there's a lot
of sadness and there's a lot of
confusion of dealing with like
coming-of-age and trying to figure that
stuff out what was the introduction of
this project like what was you know how
was it kind of pitch to you script was
it book was it so I'd worked with the
producers before Tina and Kim and so
they've had it for so long I had four
years and I was always hearing about it
and I'm they're super passionate about
it and I was too and I was like okay
whatever I have to do to play face I'll
do it I'm in and so it just was going
around they were trying to find the
right leading man and then they found
Cameron so I think it all kind of came
together after he found Cameron did you
happen to watch any old like MTV emo
music videos because this definitely had
the feel of like a 90s emo music video
did yeah yeah I can see that I
definitely watched a lot of 93 videos
for a kid that grew up in the 90s you
know I mean I graduated high school in
2000 so we if this movie takes place
right around the same age that you are
portraying and yeah right and you know
your haircut was definitely I didn't
have that haircut because my dad cut my
hair every day like my I never went to a
barber my dad cut my hair in the in the
garage
no yeah yeah yeah in like an old barber
chair just like it was a buzz and that's
what I had yeah what did you what was
some of the things that people in 1997
were kind of were giving you stuff about
it was mostly from wardrobe and
everything else like no one really
honestly I don't think we really
Descalso we listen to a lot of music
was given like playlists and all kinds
of things which I loved and now I even
had a 90 steam birthday this year I love
the music so much and um I wore socks
with my sandals today felt 90s was the
best thing and the music and everything
but I mean yeah no one I guess people
just told me stories from their teenage
years and everyone started reminiscing
and just like it kept bringing up things
and the school was really old that we
that we filled in and that was bringing
up memories for people so it was cool
one of the things that I always noticed
was the like the sportsman Walkman did
anybody get to keep that or I don't
think anyone kept that I kept so much of
my wardrobe though I saw so much of it
but I wonder if Cameron got to take that
yeah because that's where I you know
like making mixtapes for girls he had
crushes on that's so cool we're still
around nobody does anything like that
anymore
I made CDs always thrown the CDs I had
my you know little like CD our burner
that I had plugged into my USB and you
know I'd gotten that a little bit we I
like I was always walking around with my
little portable CD player and like it
had the shot guard but it would still
always like jump in scratch we were just
like one generation behind you guys look
at some of that stuff like you know in
the 90s was the hair down to here and
then in my generation it was the here is
a deeper swoosh swoosh yeah all that emo
stuff so you know we had our own hair
catastrophes going on do you think that
like the 90s kind of I mean like I don't
want to take away anything from
technology now because everything is
kind of fantastic yeah that like that
90s time when the only communication you
had was like AOL Instant Messenger do
you ever kind of feel like jealous of
that at all sometimes the mystery is
kind of nice I feel like sometimes you
know too much about people and there's
something about missing someone and not
having that like I wish someone would
just spontaneously show up for my
doorstep one day and just be like I'm in
love of you I was I was born 93 so I was
kind of growing up with the tail and a
bit so I was exposed to that to a
certain extent but I don't know III
think that 90's was such a great time
for an independent film that I think
that
a lot of those movies became iconic into
the the aughts so I had already been
exposed to a lot of media from that time
and a lot of music like I grew up
listening to Tribe Called Quest's and De
La Soul and like all of that stuff like
their old-school hip-hop was always kind
of my thing so like and actually that
was like the thing one of the first
things I did when I talked to Robin our
director I was like dude we got to get
some of these songs into the movie
absolutely and you know yeah we did we
have a pretty cool soundtrack you know
there's like we had to fight for a bunch
of the songs to be in there but I think
it's really worth it at the end I think
so too because it there are those scenes
where and like every teenager has those
moments where you just put a knee or
whatever kind of headphones you have and
you get lost in that music and you you
know whether it's drinking whether it's
weed whether it is whatever whether it's
getting lost in the music you do have
those moments of solitude in the movie
that are powerful moments within it yeah
absolutely I mean that's kind of one of
the main arcs of the character is sort
of he is searching for escapism he's in
that quest for just a solitude an escape
from himself because the the
circumstances that he's in he doesn't
understand and he doesn't quite have the
means he had to understand them he's
yearn to process them so he's escaping
the music in skating and weed and all
that stuff is what he does so like
having that not be a feature the
soundtrack would have been a pretty big
mistake yeah a lot of teenage movies I
feel like sometimes it's just like teens
against parents and I didn't get that
from that's that's what was a big thing
for them because and Juliette Lewis
she's such an incredible actress and she
plays it so well because I feel like
that is the relationship with parents
yes there are those those moments but
also there is so much love for them and
when you're a teenager I feel like you
rely on your parents more than you do as
a child even like you need them they're
even though you push them away so much
you need them there in your life and so
I feel like they did a good job with
that and I feel like Tina's such a great
mother in life that she wanted to make
sure that that was um that that was on
camera and came across and it did I
think in teen angsty movies you always
get this this look that the parents are
the problem screw you mom yeah you know
it's like no it's not that she I mean
she brings so much youth to it that she
all she always just has that natural she
kind of feels like a little bit like a
teenager herself
now you know why she's still so in
talented immature but she has just that
that youthful energy that I think works
so well in the dynamic with her and Luke
you know it's it's just I think it's
cool that we have a positive maternal
son relationship it's not something you
see oh yeah what was the hardest most of
like the most difficult scene for you to
film because it is again and it's an
emotional movie and there's that then
there's all that in this I think
this it's funny because this didn't even
really come across on camera and but it
was when I had to run up to the scene of
the crime where Stan was just hit and I
just fall to my knees and break down
sobbing and just like cried and cried
and cried and it was such a release for
me actually hidden yeah I was waiting
around all day for them to get to my
shot like waiting around all day to do
this sobbing scene and you're just
thinking about it and then dissipation
is coming up and and then I got to it
and oh my gosh I just I think they just
let me cry for like 20 minutes
it just kept going and kept going and
then Robin would just come over that our
director just come hug me be like all
right we're gonna go again okay don't
hug me though comforted by you my first
introduction to you was on shameless and
obviously I'm a giant shameless fan next
we I host Collider TV talk on this
channel so we talked about shameless all
the time and in shameless you have those
moments of like you play a very serious
character on that show do 50 very
serious very serious show of course
Gallagher doesn't exactly have the
comedic relief that a Frank Gallagher
does and the show yeah this is probably
a stupid question but do you feel like
you you pull a lot for me and Gallagher
into this character um I think that both
of them pull for myself okay I think
that it's all coming from a general
source I mean you know without getting
into like method acting what is method
acting all that [ __ ] at the end of
the day like we use her own we use our
own clap for that well you use our own
experiences in our own knowledge to
inform our characters and that we try to
exist you know
genuinely and honestly within
circumstances of what these characters
would be yeah but
I think that I have a lot of my
adolescence and youth and understanding
of myself put it into Ian what was
interesting about Ian was that I've been
working on that movie for like ten years
so that was like a journey of
self-discovery
and coming of age with that character as
well and this one I had the little bit
of the benefit of reflection I have some
level of disconnect now I'm not a
teenager anymore I shot the movie a
couple years ago so I wasn't that far
away from a teenager but still I had
just a couple of years to look back and
go okay this is what I I experienced and
with this what I could get out of it but
and both I we learned I learned lessons
about myself and put them into the
projects you know just [ __ ] I know I
really enjoyed the movie and the movies
out Friday and it's on demand you guys
can check it all out there anthem of a
teenage prophet
Peyton lists before I let you go we're
gonna do some rapid fire questions okay
you want to do that yes you know this is
just getting to know you as fast as we
possibly can okay do you make lists yes
do you read your horoscope no dogs or
cats cats would you go to Burning Man
the baby yeah funniest thing a fan has
asked you to ask you sign their breasts
I was like 15 - and I was like and I was
too sweet and I was like okay that's did
you have an AOL screen name yes I did
what was it I still use it with another
thing so there's a 1957 movie called
Peyton Place do you one know it and - is
there a plan for you to remake it all
people always came up to me as a K and
were like that is a show or a movie or
whatever and then the only other time I
saw my name was when I was in Brooklyn
and I was biking and it said Peyton's
play pin and I was like mom dad look
Payton's play pin they're like oh let's
keep riding guy that's not Mets of the
two places I've seen my name gentleman's
gentleman slug what's your dream car
Aston Martin Michael Jackson or Prince
Prince McDonald's or Wendy's McDonald's
do you sleep on your back side or
stomach stomach it's weird it's super
salad salad babies are puppies babies
sweet or salty sweet beach or pool
cool did you have an imaginary friend ah
no I had the work like considering I'm
an actress I had the worst imagination
as a kid I'd be like no I need some real
friends you ever said let's go out
dancing oh hell yeah every night boy can
you play an instrument yeah guitar drums
harmonica ukulele a few boy queso dip or
guacamole uh Occam only comedy or drama
yeah drama d so per body wash neither
just kidding have you ever brought
stinky food onto an airplane do you eat
cereal yes but I Batman or Superman
you eat dry cereal no milk Batman
favorite SNL cast member Oh Kristen Wiig
Kristen Wiig I like it do you wash your
hands after the bathroom every time yes
yeah I think you're just trying to catch
people here if Heaven were a place on
earth where would it be ah at my house
Sabrina the Teenage Witch or Clarissa I
that might I don't know if you know
Clarissa okay
I've watched Sabrina the Teenage Witch
way more okay especially going on there
you go what celebrity do you'd like to
speak at your wedding yeah Nelson
Mandela dr. Dre Snoop Dogg dr. Jay box
zucchini UFC Oh
boxing you get carsick yes
Fisher chicken chicken chicken her steak
chicken beer wine beer mozzarella sticks
or fried calamari mozzarella sticks
dirty dancing or Footloose Dirty Dancing
I love that answer
Oh do you own any cassettes yes Cheetos
or Doritos and Cheetos Elton John or
Billy Joel Elton John are you a cuddler
yeah
our vegans just the worst no they're all
right Andre the Giant Hulk Hogan Hulk
Hogan I like it dogs or cats dogs I'm
watching would you go to Burning
and yeah I was just looking at videos of
Burning Man really Eminem is a Reese's
Pieces M&Ms insert and sinker Backstreet
Boys NSYNC go-to karaoke song
faith by George Michael like Guns and
Roses and Metallica when you wake up
what's the first thing you check on your
phone then email
Michael Jackson or Prince oh my gosh
Prince you could be the leader of any
band in history what band would it be oh
my gosh the Beatles single coming out
yeah along with this movie yeah is it
amazing that's the greatest song of all
time of all time so I thought yeah it's
called dance till we die that's an
amazing title of a song thank you I know
what not enough people are dancing
anymore I know I'm like going off right
why aren't people more people dancing I
completely agree I go out and people
just sit there and they nod their heads
especially models in LA and everything
and I just don't care enough I haven't
covered I'm soaking in sweat I had two
suits made for my wedding cuz I knew I'd
sweat through one of them that's amazing
yeah why should why should the girl be
the only one to have alpha changes
correct
my wife had four martini or Manhattan
and hadn't do you floss yeah you ever
been skydiving no do you how to tie a
bow tie
you know what if you owned a bar what
would you call it oh my god you see is
it what is it Peyton's place finally
jeopardy or Wheel of Fortune jeopardy is
Disneyland or Disney World the happiest
place on earth
yeah Cameron Monaghan star of anthem of
a teenage prophet dude again
congratulations thanks for being on whoo
I think I want to change it from cats to
dogs
I regretted that one as it was coming
out of my mouth it's gonna be held
against me it's it's a cat person he
caught him it's dogs all right again
thank you man Congrats on anthem of a
teenage prophet it's great it's on
demand it's out in theaters this Friday
you were great
thank you and you were great in the
moving you're great here and I think all
the clutter fans will say the exact same
thing so again thank you so much for
being a list everyone LA
[Music]